dans une semaine patrick dils se saura
s'il sera ou non rejugé il avait été
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité pour le meurtre de deux
enfants lorraine il y a plus de dix ans
la commission de révision des procès
doit statuer sur son cas
ce sont les déclarations du tueur en
série francis heaulme qui ont conduit
l'avocat de 10 à déposer un recours
depuis de nouveaux témoins sont apparus
dans ce dossier enquête
sl mathieu ifk mnr il y a plusieurs
jours dans sa prison de toul
patrick dils purge sa 14e année de
prison à 16 ans il est condamné pour le
meurtre de deux enfants
aujourd'hui il a 30 ans voici son
témoignage obtenir leur non pas de la
vérité malheureusement j'étais la bonne
poire la pression c'est que je suis une
certitude c'est à dire c'est à dire que
on ne va pas toucher
j'ai eu aucun coup
les pressions géothermie c'est à dire
que c'est une pression au niveau
psychologique et morale du mental retour
sur une tragédie 1987 la lorraine dans
la banlieue de metz sur ces photos
patrick 10 et on garde à vue pas de
mobile mais des aveux quatorze ans après
l'inspecteur chargé d'une enquête est
toujours aussi convaincu suis toujours
persuadé que deans
patrick est bien l'auteur du double
meurtre de montigny par contre s'il est
exact qu'il ya encore une zone d'ombré
au jour d'aujourd'hui il me paraît
évident que la justice doit tout faire
aussi bien par des tests adn que par une
enquête complémentaire pour éliminer
ceux de toutes les zones d'ombré
justement sur la base d'un élément
nouveau patrick dils a demandé la
révision de son procès l'élément nouveau
c'est la présence de francis heaulme le
tueur en série français sur les lieux du
crime le jour des faits l'élément
nouveau c'est l'excusé graal qu'il
n'obtiendra au cours d'une audition
comme celle ci ap graal comme est bizone
il a arrêté puis souvent faibles
exki français dans l'est de la france
prête plus long d'une voie de chemin de
fer près des poubelles et d'un monde
qu'ils avaient vu des gamins qui avaient
jeté des pierres mais que plus tard et
évoluent dans l'idée du roman de
corriger ces gamins ou s'adresser à eux
et que lorsque tu arrivais y avait des
policiers les gendarmes et que les
gamins étaient morts
les corps est pas bon il y avait du cran
dit jamais qu'il a tué quelqu'un et
vous rêvez les moeurs mais toujours
arriver sur les scènes de crime où l'ua
rencontrer l'assassin qui lui a expliqué
comment ça s'était passé du la précision
en fait de ses descriptions et là on est
exactement dans le cadre d'ailleurs sur
le mode opératoire proprement dit c'est
exactement sa façon de faire plus
récemment et plus surprenant il ya cette
déclaration de l'un des avocats des
familles des victimes
dans son cabinet il y à un mois
il a reçu les confidences e spontanée de
trois personnes celle de deux officiers
de police d'abord et bien que d'une part
le jour de la reconstitution
plusieurs personnes âgées sont présentés
aux policiers hauts commandants des
forces de police qui gardaient les lieux
de la reconstitution pour s'étonner que
la personne qui était incriminé soit un
jeune alors que dans leur esprit celui
qui se noue le témoignage des
témoignages avait fait le coup était une
personne âgée quand on sait que holes et
édenté on peut penser que peut-être
ces personnes pensaient à lui sert d'une
femme enfin marguerite soko le jour des
faits se trouvait sur un balcon face à
la fameuse ben ou patrick dils était
venu chercher des timbres quatorze ans
après elle raconte et j'ai vu monsieur
venir avec à sac sur le dos qu'est ce
qui vous permet de dire que c'est lui
écoutez sa chevelure déjà pied le roux
ya ce moment-là qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ben lui l'appui là il est rentré
chez lui 1
c'est à dire que vous êtes en train de
dire qu'à aucun moment il ne s'est
dirigé vers les enfants jamais jamais
jamais jamais fermé
pourquoi ces témoignages cardiff dans ce
dossier que reste-t-il des confidences
des coïncidences troublantes aucune
preuve aucun mobile et un condamné
patrick dils le 28 juin prochain
la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation rendra son arrêt quoi qu'il en
soit la procédure est exceptionnel
pourra-t-elle conduire un jour à la
vérité chacun espère